Maurice Glory est retraité et bénévole
au resto du cœur depuis plus de 2 ans il
s'occupe de l'entrepôt de l'association
basée au clés sous-bois l'année dernière
l'équipe des bénévoles a préparé 1400
palettes pour approvisionner les 26
centres que compte le département des
ivelines on gère à peu près 120 types
d'articles pour la distribution donc ça
va sur tout ce qui est l'accompagnement
classique les pâtes le riz les conserves
après vous avez toute une série de
protides tout ce qui est conserve de
poisson tout ce qui est produit
surgelé vous avez après du dessert et
des produits laitiers l'objectif des
restos fournir aux bénéficiaires un
repas complet et équilibré les besoins
varieront selon les centres les plus
petits pourront servir 120 repas par
semaine tandis que les plus importants
en distribueront 4000 l'entrepô stock
plus de 80 % de marchandises
alimentaires le reste se réparti entre
produits d'hygiène et d'entretien pour
les bébés couch laid de croissance et
petits pot destinés à près de 500
nourrissons chaque semaine si si la
campagne d'hiver des Restos du cœur
vient juste de débuter à l'entrepôt on
prépare déjà les palettes pour la
semaine suivante la distribution
commence ce matin et on est parti pour
officiellement 16 semaines mais
traditionnellement on fait 17 semaines
on démarre en début en début de campagne
à 45000 et on finira à plus de 60 le
nombre de bénéficiaires ne cesse de
croître et les bénévoles sont plus que
jamais recherchés autre difficulté la
disparition du Programme européen d'aide
au plus démunis ça représente 20 25 %
des approvisionnements
donc si brut tellement ça disparaît ben
je pense qu'on a pas de solution
instantanée pour remplacer ça donc on
espère que les politiques seront
mobilisés pour maintenir ce budget façon
de
faire